fluor gang floor gang sitting on the
floor recording videos for millions of
viewers gang yeah sunburned gang I went
outside one gang I know I listen I have
garden now I may have garden now but I
don't have table now it's a tough life
that's not why you clicked on this video
you clicked on this video for some epic
inget issue some epic English Japanese
anime I don't know what I call it I
don't know why it's so funny
first of all not racist okay just funny
there's a difference so this clip is
called when you fire the English voice I
think just that in itself is funny
something is moving the preparatory from
the bottom also see it's heading for the
railroad stop it I like her just
syllables came out of nowhere there it's
so funny enjoy your last chain
nice I felt the urgency in that very
good
I love these they're funny I'm sure they
laugh at us the same way if we try to
speak Japanese you know what I mean my
favorite one I've seen that I've shown
this before it's a classic it's the oh
my god if you haven't seen this I mean
it's it's pure joy whatever you learn a
new language they always give you this
bizarre like sentence you're like why
would I ever say that I wish I was a
bird wish I were
is that what Japanese people learn
English I wish I were a bird Americana
you do know this what is this anime but
I only wish that a dude oh we're so oh
my god
here it is I mixed them up this is the
equipo song it's funny laughs I think
it's funny I don't care
glorg Aang if you floor a gang you don't
care oh my god
oh my god these are prosthetics don't
feel a thing what am I do that I'm only
wearing these just so he doesn't look
awkward okay for the video I'm doing
this for the sake of the video you
[Music]
basically be trying to speak oh my god
I'm excited you know to use the ability
ability of sickness come on guys come on
don't you know this everyone knows this
everyone to be fair the Japanese
language like to borrow a lot of English
words which already sounds kind of funny
yeah you feel you feel like you're
almost not supposed to say it you're
something like I don't I don't think I'm
supposed to say that like food food
related items especially are usually
appropriated from the English language
like curries kadhi I think and coffees
Kohi what else for ku it's for what good
spoon spoon hmm there we go
kay on the movie I didn't know I had a
movie i watch this back in the day oh my
god why are you going which one
[Music]
I can't relate so hard to this I'm like
I prepared the sentence I'm supposed to
say and I say it they're the best of my
ability but then they get a question
back and I'm like ah and then they speak
perfectly English I know I'm laughing at
Japanese people speaking bad English but
surprising a lot of Japanese people
speak really good English
it's always so humiliating like oh yeah
I guess I'm speaking English what would
be the English version of that I love
tea I love meatballs I'll just pull that
next time I mess up German bras tell me
if that was accurate as I can tell that
was spot-on yeah it's funny though I
mentioned like one word in Russian and
all the Russian bros are like oh my god
I say one word in Japanese in like
that's not how you say that cringe she
got it all wrong the way you conjugate
that verb
we go into Japan that's exactly what
happens I feel like Jojo oh yeah they
definitely Jodie has a ton of I gotta
get Jo doing their George oh should we
just start god damn is so quick it's so
funny it's not funny in this context jo
du-sik what is it granddad always swears
in English it is so funny because it's
so out of place
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye judges this is not voice acting
but it's when you fire all the activator
same channel as before it's basically
the same humor at the same oh my god oh
they're trying they're trying their best
okay oh my god even though this is just
his face forever it's a puppet
it looks like they just took the
storyboard and even made that into an
animation oh my god did you see the
woman in the back Jesus Christ that's
terrifying
he's still back I feel a little bad
because obviously I mean I don't know
the context why it became like this
sometimes they got a crunch for time I
don't know maybe sometimes people just
go oh my god oh wow
it keeps going oh it's like PD PI video
quality level when they just finish the
keyframe where this is episode two we're
supposed to air tomorrow
now it goes up now that's even that's
funny
I like this anyway I might watch it yeah
it's on par with the Joker this reminds
me of another video I got in my
recommendation listen I don't watch
anime by the way that's for nerds
turning anime to 60 yes
hey I I'm going off on a tangent here I
am aware it's an anime tiny isn't that
dope
I love that part when they do they have
Joe Broz right there look at the Winx
look the Winx oh my god it fly like
angel dude it looks cool come on how do
they do that
I mean yeah this one looks go look at
that that looks amazing it looks unreal
what is that anyway I want to watch that
all right you get the point
yeah so I'm gonna buy Georgia darts i'ma
get really bad but yeah I agree it was
good stuff to me usually when I saw me
yeah like a cape blowing better that's
what makes good
something with consistent movement yeah
I understand that why it's good isn't
this what people already do when they
say fake super-slow-motion
I need to make a jojo video at some
point it's jojo week after all just wish
jojo fans weren't as obnoxious like
vegans otherwise maybe as you do
[Music]
and I don't care about their feelings
let it be known I don't care about these
feelings a lot of different emotions and
reactions to the bees I understand it
the controversial people everyone has a
different opinion I get it what is this
job exactly I'm so confused another
anime to my enemy list
we'll watch maker of visa huh both of
its know he'll gain there give me some
right well come on but the [ __ ] trying
to say badass all right yeah I think
we're run out of the funny if you
enjoyed this episode sorry I geeked out
sometimes it happened subscribe to the
channel I upload every single date
doesn't matter if I have tables or not
there will be a video see you tomorrow
gamers hopefully with the table I don't
know it's close to arrive goddamnit
it was supposed to arrive today and
hopefully my skin will not be a tomato
you don't you know what's big peepees do
they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course pixel ings
is a creature collecting game I'm the
primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it
build with it
[Music]
you